all right we're having a tough time
keeping our cameras straight this
morning because the wind is shaking them
up
so much out there uh we're going to have
those
gusty winds through the morning and the
afternoon kiddo 70 degrees this morning
we're looking for a cooler afternoon
though in the mid 80s
wind gusts have already reached 40 miles
an hour and we expect
that they're going to stay pretty rough
and even get rougher through the day so
far saint rose parkway 40 mile an hour
winds
red rock near 40 mccarran and nellis mid
30s as far as mile per hour winds and
southern highlands
also the same so all right i'm using
nate's trash can today
as an example of what's going on with
the wind forecast yep there it goes
blowing down the street
nate go get your trash can all right so
we're looking at gusty winds 25 30 miles
an hour through the morning
30 to 40 midday and maybe 35 to 45
plus through the afternoon and evening
hours wind advisories
for all of southern nevada go into
effect 11 a.m to 11
p.m with those winds 40 to 50 miles an
hour also
fire weather warnings now up at mount
charleston nv energy
is looking to shut down the power to
about 500 customers up there
and they did this back in april and they
might do it again today
just to avoid any wildfire danger up
there
if they do it'll go the power will go
off about one o'clock and for about 21
hours so
they did it back in april and to avoid
wildfire danger
of these power lines coming down and
sparking a wildfire
in the very dry conditions they will set
up a resource center
at the mount charleston retreat center
and then you can have wi-fi
ice you can plug in your phones and
devices if you need them up there so
they will
have available resources for the folks
but it's almost 500 residents that
will be out of power for a long time but
it worked in april so they might do it
again today
with these strong winds we're going to
look for areas of blowing dust today
highs in the mid 80s the winds will turn
to out of the north northwest later
today
and then we'll still be breezy tomorrow
but not as windy and temperatures much
cooler look at those low 70s 70's
for friday mid 70's saturday low 80's
sunday boy we just inch our way back to
90's next week